damn all such discussion thinking
outside of the box would follow the
example of the matrix and say there is
no box the only the box we create
ourselves there is no box that separates
us producers from consumers there is no
box that forces the sonoma modes of
thinking there is no box and isolates
the Academy problem commercial space
those are the boxes we're trying to
break down this weekend and we're hoping
it will be able to engage in a dialogue
together often when we hear from
industry people we hear concerns about
losing control and this is a
conversation we had an Austin rather
lock clients are worried that they're
going to lose control in the new media
landscape I think the opening clip
illustrates the fact that you've already
lost control right that we can take your
media and do with it whatever we want we
can create our own media we can conserve
our selves into it we could even if we
wanted to replace Keanu Reeves with a
real actor but uh you know we can
redefine the media as we understand that
consumers are already doing that so the
challenge is not about giving up control
it's about accepting a new relationship
with consumers one that requires a
negotiated relationship one that means
building new sort of moral Ecology's you
dialogues with consumers and that's
really what we're here to talk about
today that we're here to explore
together what this new space will look
like and to build on some ideas that are
emerging from the research we've been
doing in convergence culture yeah I mean
it's lovely um we're just going to do a
quick scroll through some of the things
that we've looked at this first year and
kind of amp up so what's coming after
that our big stories
right now it's an ideal time to be able
to work without boundaries we can afford
to experiment we can afford to see test
out what can happen see what some of the
limits are get some feedback get some
information some of it ethnographic some
of the database the different ways and
means of which were working and see okay
so how are we going to make this new
world so we're point2 20 ubiquitous
computing virtual worlds mobile social
networks these are all things that we're
looking at studying as a group as a
partnership so we're bringing together
today leading academics from literally
around the world who are thinking about
these questions we've some of the
smartest people we've met in the media
industries for a conversation now I
don't imagine this first conversation
we're all going to say the right things
or use the right language the academics
are working hard to speak common English
it's a second language for many of us
but we're working at it at the same time
we hope corporate people will meet us
halfway and will if they're things you
don't understand ask you know if they're
think questions you don't get raise them
I'm still struggling with how to speak
business English myself I haven't quite
figured out whether a chief knowledge
officer is a higher rank than a chief
wisdom law officer or a lower rank it's
sort of a complicated terrain the
language of modern business but I'm
hoping that we can try to find a common
vocabulary this week it's a chance for
us to introduce to each other the key
players on both sides of this sort of
relationship that we're building
together and get to know get to know
each other a little better so we hope
it'll be informal dialogic
conversational it was mean the same
thing once the academic version the
others in business version
conversational and we hope that we can
learn from each other and form guilt
okay
so one as many of you know part of what
led me to be interested in creating this
was that I'd written this book that's
coming out this summer this is my
shameless plug moment convergence
culture we're old and new media collides
and tied to that the book fans go augers
and gamers so this is going to be part
of a larger conversation ironically
enough I just got to be Africa was
asking me on the Editorial Board of a
journal called convergence so which has
been going on for some time so
convergence as a category is beginning
to build more bugs there's more
discussion about it but I think what we
mean by convergence in our discussion
has been sort of thinking about the new
relationships that between consumers
producers brands and entertainment
content that is convergence is not a
technological process for us it's a
cultural process it's a set of shifts in
the way our culture operates when we may
not live in a world where the technology
speak easily to each other we may not
live in a world where there's a single
black box that flows the controls the
flow of media we do live in a world
where every story every idea every brand
every relationship is going to play
itself out across the broadest possible
number of media and that's the world of
convergence culture is we're talking
about it in the context at MIT what
we've been looking at entertainment as
marketing so the implicit contract the
trust in multiple levels of from both
the tech and the style of how a brand
works and how product placement works
alec is in the back and grant mccracken
is in the back we can blame these two so
take your questions to them okay um
Fanning the audience's flames both Henry
and Sam Ford he's around here someplace
tempted the primary research on this
what does it need to cultivate the space
for the consumer to become participate
in maker consumer as several people
instrument theorize this is a dead words
and disease
so here we're looking at that and
in-game advertising Illya is the
researcher on this paper and
fundamentally we have to understand the
worlds that weren't working in and if
you're working in a virtual world an MMO
or a console game you have to understand
the context in what you're working to be
able to those are thumbnails guarantees
okay this term we've begun work on some
ambitious new projects which we hope to
deliver as the summer as we get into the
summer the first we're going to
reference today is an ongoing
ethnography that we're doing inside
dorms here at MIT understanding young
young people's relationship with media
the referral economy the way tastes gets
shaped the way social consumption or
media takes place and that's been
mirrored forced by our friends at GSD&M
working with folks at the University of
Texas at Austin we are also in the
process of collecting a large data set
of response of people across the country
of college students along similar
questions and we'll be able to compare
as they at the end of this first phase
some qualitative research in two
locations with some larger scale
statistical analysis being performed by
some of our friends at Sloan who are
very much part of this team we're going
to work Alec Austin this term is working
with us on paper called promotion versus
prohibition file sharing digital rights
management a new digital marketplace and
it's really looking at new business
models new relations between media
producers and consumers we're going to
be looking at alternative reality games
and Ivan asked with who was introduced
the session is doing a paper for us this
is not an advertisement understanding
the use of alternative reality games and
consumer engagement and this is a
growing trend in the Indus in the
industry more and more of alternative
reality games armor
urging most famously I love bees but a
variety of others and it's a model that
I think we all need to understand better
because it does seem to mobilize the
collective intelligence of fans and
consumers and interesting ways I Ilya
will be working with us this term on
emerging advertising technologies and
models as some of you know his blog he's
been pulling together over a long period
of time really interesting stuff about
cutting-edge approaches to advertising
then this will sort of grow out of that
research and finally moving stories a
mobile media I PT and new models for
digital storytelling and that's the work
that Jeffrey long who is here is working
on this term trying to think about new
modes of entertainment the so-called
mobis ODEs new systems of distribution
of video content so the all the people
involved in those papers are around for
the conference we hope as we get breaks
and conversations some of these issues
will come up we encourage you to grab
people and talk to them share your
interest in those papers any insights
connections you might have that would be
relevant to the people working on those
projects we began with the spoon
sequence from the matrix we're going to
in our section with a second clip from
the same phone change I don't know the
future I didn't come here and tell you
how this is going to end even the king
and tell you how it's going to begin I'm
going to hang up this phone and then I'm
going to show these people that you
don't want them to see I'm going to show
them a world without
a world without rules and controls
without borders or boundaries a world
where anything is possible where we go
from there is a choice of the team
I'll see Josie three is that we don't
need to fear that world we need to
understand that we need to build it
together so that we preserve the
meaningful economic and cultural
relationships that allow the
entertainment economy to operate that we
get consumers what they want we get
brands and media producers what they
want but we renegotiate the rules and
what happens next is up to us so that's
said I'm going to turn the floor over to
my colleague William Riccio we'll talk
some about media change
okay with luck the audio is working um I
just like to take advantage of the fact
that we in a museum to talk a little bit
about technology and history to talk
about the two cultures that Henry
referred to a notion that there are
things in the world that shape us in
certain ways that there are also things
that people do to transform those things
is that there's a synergy there's an
interaction and I guess the bottom line
of what I'll be talking about is the way
in which we can think about technologies
have certainly disruptive we've all
heard about disruptive technologies but
in fact that there are ways that they're
only disruptive uses of technology and
that's really one of the key sites
that's where innovation comes from
that's where we purposely comes from and
I'd like to just begin with a kind of a
historiographic reference one of the
great problems with history and you
would think that professional historians
have sorted this out on their own but
there seems still to be some confusion
with the number of my esteemed
colleagues in that discipline because
you we all know that I mean we tend to
have a lot of slippage in our language
and this is not just the English
language but it's also show in German we
think of history as what happened in the
past but we know that history is the
stories we tell about what happened in
the past and those two don't meet what
happened in the past I mean what's
happening in this room now there's an
infinite number of things with an
infinite number of points of view
there's no one correct way to represent
it but historians seem bothering to
confuse in the critics of course to
confuse that into think that somehow the
inadequacies with historical modeling is
that they've missed something in the
past or they deform something in the
past that's inevitable and I guess our
language doesn't do us any favors by
kind of suggesting that both of those of
history and I guess what I'd like to
stress by the green color that every
every age asks its own questions of the
past is that one of the marbles to me of
history is to look back at different
versions of how history has been called
because while that tells us something
about the French Revolution or even
invention of the printing press or
whatever what it really tells us about
is the moment in which that historical
so for example in our prison and I would
say maybe for the last 20 years or so
the rise of you know in academic
parlance something like post
structuralism which is all about the end
of certainty in the end of the master
narrative and this kind of highly
reference self-reflexive and
self-referential notions of history
which a lot of people have problems with
facticity to the past that's really
about a moment in which we have
technologies like hypertext a moment
that we now would baby talk about more
in terms of web two point oh where we
have different points of view we have
different people collaborating and
participating we have a multi voiced
narrative of collaborative collective
narrative sure there's no certainty
there it's far more of a dynamic process
but because that's the technological and
cultural moment we inhabit one of the
things that's been happening you can we
go back and model or history of the
French Revolution or the invention of
the printing press we're suddenly asking
the questions asking questions that are
informed by that kind of hauling vocal
or pollen seema Crescent that we inhabit
so it makes older historical model seem
a bit old-fashioned at least
cutting-edge people and it makes current
history look a little bit dodgy to
people that prefer their history more
traditional so I just say all of this to
frame my comments today because they're
coming what I'd like to do is just use
some of the questions that are coming up
you know some of the conditions that are
in our present web two point over the
shorthand but a much bigger away
conditions and to revisit some moments
in the media past moments that have you
know certainly historical narratives
around them but we're seeing that those
narratives are now changing we're asking
new questions of the past and what do
you know we're finding out things about
the pass to actually speak to our prison
so rather than thinking that there's
some profound rupture between now and
then between the old stuff of the past
and the new world we're bravely munching
into I guess what I'd like to suggest in
the next few minutes is that there are
any enormous number of lessons to be
learned from the past if we change the
questions we put to the test
one of the things we see in our present
is the problem of identity this is an
object just a lot of us would call it a
cell phone but we're seeing increasing
ambiguity about what precisely this
object is and when you look at marketing
campaigns the state's is probably not
the best example for this but in Asia or
in Europe where phone technology as an
attitude the evolutionary ladder parties
game platforms arby's location devices
are these communication devices
primarily are these I mean there's any
number of these music downloading
platforms what precisely is this object
and it's it's interesting to what is
this a platform to watch television I
mean right now in Holland Vodafone
attorney has tried to sort of target its
advertising to all of those different
editions of this object and it depends
what ads you're seeing or what journals
you're reading what this thing might be
called appellant what its promises are
so that moment of instability in a
technology is actually it's actually
kind of old and so one way to sort of go
back and look at the past would be to
take a medium that we think we
understand pretty well for example we
could go back and look at photography
now for most of us most of us live but
also let's go put on the older side and
who have made the switch from sort of
analog cellular base photography
photochemical face photography to
digital probably we still think of
photographs as as a way to make
something and potentially to make copies
of it it's about a way to hold the past
but also to sort of replicate the past
but if we go back to the birth of
photography actually it was a very
interesting mixed message much like
there is today with the cell phone a
very interesting leaks message about
what this medium was the french and de
guerre was probably the most exemplary
his name of course stuck to this
currently understood photography as a
way to make very precise recordings of
the world very very precise copies of
the world but not copies of that copy
the carrots heights are unique
they were like a painting there's only
one we don't make any of the same then
you make one so here are there was an
idea of singularity was taken for
granted because that's a painting work
here the idea was precision of some sort
of recording of the outside world a lot
of other lessons with daguerreotype by
the way we could have see in a minute
his competitive proxy Albert in Britain
but the French government bought the
patent from beginner and made it the
worldwide made it available for the
world with the idea of branding
photography as a French invention so
there's a little side message there this
kind of interesting but here I really
want to focus on the ambivalence of what
this medium was for you to cross over
into bread and Britain the British
contender for the inventor of the medium
is a guy named Fox caliber would be
marvelous work but his whole fixation
was on coming up with a negative based
process so that you could copy and
reproduce so that multiplicity was the
advantage to painting where de Guerra
this was a more precise painting a
painting that no painter could could get
you know that precise from fox talbot
this was about being able to take an
image and reproduce it endlessly two
totally different notions of the same
medium in contestation for a while so I
just you know look at our use of the
cell phone today and think back to the
roots of the economy today this is not a
finishing we think about we know what
the prog raphy is for doing because now
at least for a younger generation
photography isn't sure it's about
capturing the moment insurance about
making copies but increasingly it seems
to be about building a network about
finding friends who shared experience
about linking your images with people
that you may not know but we will get to
know basis so there seems to be sort of
a third life for this movie minute I
don't think any of us feel is that the
medium has been challenged pinner the
fundamental rang but I think if you
watch this sort of slippery
repositioning of the medium it's
actually kind of interesting now all
three of these examples for photography
your kind of technology-based obviously
with some submissions from people and
some interpretations from people I'd
like to focus a little more on this
notion of the disruptive uses
and you know Napster is a great example
of that no one really imagined when they
were building the internet or when they
were developing with different
algorithms or compression algorithms and
protocols that some kid was going to
come up with this strategy to subvert
the music industry as we know it that
was never in the plan and we all know
that no matter how technologically
rigorous we try to be about developing
new encryption technologies or whatever
is probably some clever to be living
there old boy out there and he's going
to crack it so what I'd like to do is
just take this notion of disruption and
move it away from the kind of RIA
nightmare notion of creativity and
actually show how creativity this point
to a few quick examples of how user
appropriation how disruptive use has
wound up on the things that we really
take for granted today there's lessons
just a lot of divergent lessons here and
I'm just going to pop through a couple
of them but one of them has to do with
the book the book is a really
interesting technology and clearly one
that you know I think one can rightly
say really helped our civilization to
move in ways that it has I don't want to
be a technological determinist it's
clearly the book another one to do my
ability to accumulate knowledge and fix
it and there's a historian a list of
eisenstein very prominent historian of
the book whose argued extensively and in
very in very robust terms that the book
had three primary traits that really
changed the world one of them was
standardization one with dissemination
and one was fixity standardization one
of the great advantages the book CAD
plugins eisenstein over their old script
days to manage good days was that you
didn't have to worry about a sleeping
copyist who might forget a word or
forget alone misspell something you know
every book looks the same as long as
it's coming from the same printed setup
looks set up but the typeface you're
going to get pretty much the same not
pretty much you're going to have
precisely the same material and what
that means is that if you disseminated
the second point suddenly astronomers in
Denmark and in Italy and in Britain can
compare their data with no chance of
error from a slaw
the script writer and and because of the
precious nature that hand written script
these can multiply and easily be
disseminated that's that's what will
advance the cause of science fixity that
these things are permanent they wind up
in libraries there enough of them that
they survive the test of time how my
candy scripts which can because they're
so pure that we can really disappear
from human consciousness but that's a
pretty reasonable argument and I think
most academics the sort of my generation
girlfriend definitive account was the
case in fact until recently we never
thought about we never really looked for
evidence of a different campus and the
different practice I want to if we go
back to the first say 50 to 100 years of
the book what we've seen is the books
were precious people weren't exactly
sure if some cases how it worked and
they would get plates these are mrs.
Galileo's sitarist so nucleus which is a
really what Neil sort of the key work in
terms of understanding the surface of
the Moon the mapping of it from his
Christmas from his little geographic
position in the world and as I
Eisenstein said this was widely
distributed astronomers in Denmark and
Britain could sort of comparative data
and see if they agreed and because like
to sort of sharpen up and the Pirates
weren't really careful about how they
printed the plates so that in fact
rampant piracy for something like the
books existence you can standardize it
introduced more noise than ever because
at least the manuscripts we're limited a
number was sort of had to be pretty
privileged to get them so you could
wireless be sure of its provenance in
the case of the book people could claim
well people did claim that this does
delawareans book even though they ripped
off the plates and you can just the
first the top row across his Galileo's
it's not a convincing graphic grams but
I think you can see that they if you
look at the second moon on the left you
can see that they flip the plate and
pull the crater is now at the top
Galileo looked at you know because it's
in a very dramatically different place
because these plates were circulated
over 60 70 years you can also see that
the plate start to lyric down and the
detail that Galileo so painstakingly put
into his drawings of the Moon fade away
and turn in disorder so wild distributed
knowledge was hardly fixed and it was
certainly not standing down so something
like the book introduces the problem
piracy which I don't think a lot of
folks who really Java we think that this
is a problem added digital so what we
see here is that the solution one of the
solutions became up and I use branding
in a very loose turner but the
imprimatur there where it's actually a
sign this is not a numbered edition but
it's signed on attest to the press that
made it the responsibility of the press
to guarantee that this is a correct
version so it's a little bit I think
likely think to do who would like to
think that that little brand on the bag
make sure it's his and unfortunately it
doesn't exactly but anyway you can see
when that endeavor begins to sort of fix
the quality to establish the veracity of
a particular so one of many different
examples creative repurposing is maybe
more dramatic piece baby stories which
occur entities are such dramatic
examples are just want to mention these
are everyday objects now in a state of
the radical transformation but still
there's an interesting story behind all
of these and the one worried behind the
three technologies are going to show you
his disability the three technologies
i'm about to show you were born from an
attempt to address the absence of
certain sentences so people that lack
hearing conditions required ways to get
about in the world the typewriter was
actually invented when those were the
first ideas check when the ids was
generated and when the technology sort
of evolved this is
the 18th century throughout the 19th
century pretty much until Remington and
companies like that fix on a different
model so really for about 100 years the
typewriter is imagined as a way for the
blind because you don't want to and I
don't know why go to movies a lot in
take notes when I try to decipher my
scrawl in the dark it's pretty hard and
I guess blind people don't even have the
ability to go back and correct what
they've written so they've been running
Tremont writing in the dark process this
was understood as a way that it would be
a simple you know touch train system
that would enable the boring well that's
not at all how we it's a device that's
had lots of other sort of social
implications that really helped the
gender situation for a short time and
allowed women to enter the workspace
little bit they know they'd be relegated
for the secretarial ranks but at least
been a wild when handwriting was seen as
a sort of real strong market character
and men had bald handwriting and women
had this sort of this was an instrument
of gender neutrality and a long and
interesting is to give the typewriter
but the simple point is it got to where
it is the last existed at least one okay
um yeah right right through a very
creative repurposing and obviously a
market that was significant enough to
support a telephone is another one
Alexander Graham Bell's white was deaf
he had a very wealthy father in law his
experiments were understandably
supported by his father in law and they
had a special attraction to you know try
to help his wife and other deaf people
communicate better the phone is nothing
more than the transformation of
acoustical sound waves into vibrations
physical renovations deaf people
communicate on the stage
one of the crazier side stories of the
current listing Watson you know the
famous court Watson come here I want you
to put it on the phone Watson spent the
next two years listening to static
participate they can have the idea that
the static was somehow picking up the
ether and well where does the spirit go
we have a long history of that poker
guys going alone the phonograph Thomas
Edison edem dito I mean medicine was it
was just about death the phonograph was
again a way to turn that sound the
invisible ephemeral sound came to a
trace into a little zigzaggy line that
you can read potential we need to read a
familiar but again this was a device
imagined as solving the problem of the
day by translating one sensory input
into another so these are all sort of
interesting examples I think of ways in
which the envisioned notion of the
technology was turned on its head five
users who had something else in mind a
little side note the telephone had a
very interesting life in Hungary and
it's sort of an odd life this was the
fellow that was a Edison licensee in the
Central Europe and the guy who developed
phone exchanges and that was a sort of
contribution of humanity and he did a
lot of things to the gold investor in
the American West and he's a very
interesting character but one of the
things he's started back in 1822 in
Alaska name of the mid-30s was a radio
telephone system that in fact function
as radio what you're looking at here are
the programming of the telephone so in
one case you have a concert is being
played over the phone you had a number
to dial up and a time of day to do it
or if you dialed up an hour later you
could do the news or you could hear a
drama for this thing last last into the
into the radio air so another may be
crazy and gentle but one that shows that
people and cultures purpose them in ways
to suit your needs I want to just give a
slightly more extended look at the
technology that I do a lot of work done
and that's television history of
television I'm going to try to argue to
you the television as a medium
appreciated the film and moreover what
I'd like to do is just point to the
instability a little bit like the cell
phone instability of the concept of
television we up until maybe 10 or 12
years ago thought we knew what
television the box in the living room a
bedroom that we turn on and programming
comes and it started to wiggle a little
bit thanks to the thanks to cable and
video recorder and obviously today it's
in a pound and very rapid sense of
change what I want to suggest though is
the changes that we are seeing today
we're already imagined anticipated
articulated years ago and that the
medium is only kind of recovering its
senses after about a 15 year period in
which governments and electronics
industries worked very hard to fix and
stabilize them could have gotten a lot
of ways but that's not in the interests
of electronic sector at least in the
period right after the Second World War
it's certainly not in the interest of
government argued by some at least by
the Vatican somehow had a televisual
quality i'm not sure what they look like
them the 17th century 16th century that
there you go and what you see here are
some of the various names that were used
for
but it had a variety of names and you
can sort of see there already that this
was about bundling together existing
technologies the colorful telescope this
is one of the highly it's a highly
circulated image but it's an interesting
words by it was published in there in
the British second a magazine punch so
pretty you know broad circulate
relatively broad circulation eternal
back in eighteen seventy eight so that's
two years after the invention of the
telephone physician 76 10 years later
punch comes up with this cartoon and
what we're seeing here is so Edison's
Califano scope transmits light as well
as sound actually one year after the
phone was invented nature pretty
respectable science journal had a false
report that Bell was working on a new
technology a phone that you could see
through and you can go to the
point-to-point visual access just like
the United Cousteau Galactus this was a
kind of embellishment of that idea for
the fabulous flat screen that's a nice
flat screen above the heart positioned
in the living room as it should be and
it's an older couple in England talking
to their daughter in Stallone one of the
interesting thing about 11 is early
because later concentric pictures is
that you can see the television as
quickly as helping to facilitate the
project of colonization frequently
neither China or this character alberto
vida wrote a wonderful book levante of
siècle the 20th century he's an author a
bit like Jules Darren except that he
also drew his own illustrations and he's
got a big section I have 20 30 pages on
the telephone OU scope as he called it
where he envisions a number of different
scenarios for what this medium will be
and I think it's striking that and it's
one of the earliest instantiations what
television is he is a totally diverse
array of possibilities so here's one
beautifully title to do know the
suppression of absence which is really
about presence which we know is that
we're still striving for the holodeck we
may have a way
but we know that a lot of our media
strive to achieve a sense of presence
and it again very nicely stated here
again a bit of lilo Turner motif but
clearly fishes the link between the
television the telephone that I just got
a little dispersive experts is here but
that telephone idea has been one of the
most persistent visions of television
and highly contested one usually in this
sort of way that people understand that
from decision but it is about what this
is about surveillance this is another
surveillance one this notion of it
somehow there's too much information
liquidus television could be a problem
is a huge array of these kinds of this
was an advertisement for them under this
idea that maybe too much information was
not a good thing that the beauty of the
telephone back to roba da another
wonderful example who gives us a little
story where he says well here we are
1883 we want to go to the Opera we've
got a bundle up higher coach deck for
the offer fight your way in Jericho's
get a few bucks and if it's a good 19th
century opera house you're looking at
other boxes in the audience stage
with the with the telephone OU scope but
here's another image with the telephone
scope you can sit in your bedroom feed
up on the chair and watch the stage as
if it's another vision that he has is
the kind of voyeuristic application and
we know that computers are kind of
taking this over regulation kept
voyeurism Bay in television for a long
time but we know if we look at the kind
of predominant use patterns of computers
that certain voyeuristic applications
the news this is the relational color
photos again flat screen a way to plug
into the world that's happening on side
two and even large screen public space
television and this is all in 1883 that
this guy has sort of come up with this
huge spectrum of ways that gets deployed
studying in 1935 and that same ambiguity
that same damn filaments about what
exactly this technology is come to the
fore in terms of Germany's ten-year just
about 10 years experience with daily
intelligence instead of the merge now
this is a chapter of TV's history that
has been a little bit under illuminated
for lots of reasons Germans have other
things to talk about when it comes to
the Second World War and the television
illness but the fact that this was done
with RCA's technology and licensing
that's why and once you start to pull a
thread on this particular story of these
concerns of some of the electronics
corporations it sir the story that gets
very seeming very fast so we're not
going to go there we're going to look a
little more of what helped television
ones imagine them deployed in Germany
again it's just part of a way of looking
at this flexibility and interpretation
and none of this would have been the
logo you would see on TV when the
blessing to program between shows they
should have picked us up 20 35 and late
44 anchor point Berlin collapses
concludes before Berlin surrendered
public TV somewhere between two hours
and eight hours a day I want to talk to
you about foreign different models of
what television bottle one would be the
idea that if it's a bit like cinema this
is something you should see with an
audience why well two constituencies in
Germany really love this idea that
propaganda ministry be this complicated
interface belt people are less prone to
argue with a room surrounded the thought
I might be better for that but the
socialist part of it bernards he's also
got TV for everyone so they came up with
this idea of building television halls
and Berman had about we're about 40
people were coming to a room and see but
they also build a couple of large scale
this house had about 400 seats and this
one had about eight hundred seats so
this is a large screen projection
television actually just for the record
tell you going to get a lot of stuff
with you working high definition systems
about the two thousand lines outdoor
advertisements tile television and one
of those working where every pixel was a
lamp the cable was a second model they
thought would work and this of course
your man you can imagine the electronics
industry supported this mortal what's
the idea that television is really
ungraded it's just like a radio tsipras
got a kind of an extra crew that you can
see and just like the radio Germany was
heavily into this idea of a radio in
every household so G here's television
and the TV in every household and this
was a fits into the notion that the
Nazis were in the Christmas it's not
about war a bit about a kind of economic
recovery when that failed
this particular narrative would support
that what you're seeing here are
elements from an ad campaign that was
launched to sell this idea for the
public save up now because you can run
to the store and buy a TV and you can
even see that physically the television
on the left is almost radio life in its
format these are some these are not
German models but they're typical of
what you would have found in Germany in
terms of this kind of radio since this
domesticated sense of television so when
the theatrical sense is about events
something stage in a big way sort of
like [ __ ] you remember sports TV that we
could go to the cinema and play to see
other people go to bars to see because
you want to do that socially this idea
was so fun this was this was something
that would sort of surround you as an
ambient ambient sound and image in the
school and so mega ad campaigns taking
orders for the things so a familiar idea
of television to us this is the one
that's stuck in a certain way here's a
third model do any of you know Berlin so
this building fans expect shell is still
there and what you can see behind it
with the movie poster on at David and
that's the glory of columns which is
still there so you can locate this
building it's now what what it used to
be was what it says his television
speaking locale and it was a place where
you could go talk have seen television
soon telephone and there was a national
network of this stuff that went from
from Hamburg in the northbound to
nuremberg in the south
and what this place is today it's a
payoff that uses sex points and for
those of you that have ever been walking
in one they've gotten still boots this
little television screen it's just
uncanny that you know sort of the same
it's in the same business somebody is
later okay fourth model and this was a
kind of markets you could call it
lightly telepresence pellet error but
this was using television as a control
device four engines and this was a
pretty heavily tested although as far as
I can tell not deployed and you can see
for the sequence that this one these
were like little mini televisions that
they would mount in the nose Rockets
connected by wire to the launch vehicle
and they would just think could steer it
as it learning to get the ship now the
first time actually saw that imagery was
the first Iraq war this is a quite an
old
so I guess the point is if we want to
make here is oh yeah one other thing
that's kind of interesting when you go
back through the early days to see well
if you're trying to figure out what kind
of animal it is visit movies or is it
the radio or is it telepresence and what
exact type is it telephone what is it
exactly one of the curiosities to see
where it shows up in the newspaper Rand
is television programming we're just
that the program they wind up is it a
new movie section or is it by the radio
guy wears it in the theater section or
science section and it moves around a
bit but this would just sort of be an
example so it's potentially next to a
listed next to a movie it's about radio
voice voice from the ether but if that's
around all this kind of athletes foot
and beautiful so it seems to be sort of
a very heavily the program day was
advertised like the crazy in Germany
even though most people didn't see TV
they saw that trace but anyway just to
say this also speaks to its ambivalence
or its identity its identity crisis if
you will and it's a crisis that only
gets worse when the film medium enters
the world and feels especially in the
period of late forties early fifties
went film in America feels threatened by
the coming of commercial television to
America when you start to see these ad
campaigns to try to articulate what's
the difference between our medium and
bear movie and there's a ton of these
sort of campaigns but the rest are
interesting in terms of how they try to
locate or fix a meaning for television
now I want to go back just one little
more step here to the very first days of
film because I told you that I showed
you that cinema was like televisions
clearly imagined by people in
the patents for Phil wanted enters the
world is about to me or whether me 25 so
in a certain way television was the
condition to form the horizon of
expectations when movies entered the
world movies were kind of a late comer
and may give certain things that
television could do a shorter but they
lacked it's the quality of life doing
now so if you go back and you look at
what how movies advertise themselves in
that first entry distract to see an
interesting pattern you see names like
Anna Massey over in Germany would say
Laban to building living pictures the
Vitis go right up from the word for life
the BIOS code for Biograph bios life
there's this kind of claim when film
actress the world that it's about live
to a public content now a good 12 to 15
years they did for 20 years that claimed
aliveness is kind of interesting he's
kind of electric in this period also had
this idea of drive-ins that television
they knew was something with electricity
there's a lot of fantasy pictures of
what it would be but electricity is
always corn when film is marketing
itself they to embrace this language of
electricity even know film by law in
most places had the music cranked even
though they could use electric motor
because of if you require they legally
be replayed to crank it so to call these
things are electric theaters when you're
using a an alcoholic there's an echo of
this attempt of film to position itself
within here's another the Vitis skeleton
let me see the image it's almost as if
they are live on stage the scale and the
Durant of crane but otherwise the scale
makes you think these are Co inhabiting
the space with the audience and this was
one of the real tricks to film industry
tried to use in its first deck later
self to argue that film have this
presence that
tons of cartoons like this where the
cinema effect is so real it's Darren's
it's as if it's now usually these have a
subtext about the country bumpkin who
doesn't quite understand there's a class
issue there but it's also an interesting
and persistent sales pitch for cinema
itself I mean I'm sure if you remember
when high-definition televisions prefers
marketed be and even stereo televisions
Chris Marquis very much this idea of
things jumping out of the screen energy
football players or whatever this is a
Russian version again it's the country
bumpkin the primer who's a little
confused and then a British version
where it's the cocking you can tell by
the buttons on the road and of course
this is the famous Lumiere anecdote with
your right the theory first film
screened at Paris December nineteenth
1895 put the audience in the theater but
a very revealing one and a persistent
one in the film industries and companies
say 15 and I think it's all about trying
to vote blame a position with television
and what's interesting is it almost
frequently called during the first ten
years Xu allocating the French term
actual entities in actuality is like
present and current around 19 5 or 6 20
cinema gave up on this campaign the term
that the trade pest press strategy is
for film was no longer that resignation
to the store now I've talked all about
technology and that was kind of my point
I just want to win doubt by pointing to
the fact that everything I've said about
technology that is to say that we can
take the questions we have in the
present about unstable media like cell
phones or what
back find those moments in the past
piracy and I've been concerned with that
in the present we can find that in the
past and we can find of course the
response of the people we maybe even
pick up some ideas on how to solve it
one could make precisely those same
arguments and you can use the language
of in a web two point oh if you're
talking about the text if you're talking
about what's actually in the image
that's not my point but i do want to
indicate that i don't want to stop with
technology when it's for sure telling
you that things that you today we're in
a culture of you know hi IP IP maybe the
courts keep extending it and business
keeps encouraging ever longer extensions
as making it reaches the limit and we're
very concerned about you know what's
copying but my argument would be that in
all cultures were just by reference you
see here's some of the greatest chips
period actors keen and Garrick and Betty
but and what you're seeing is the ghost
seen enamel and you're seeing if they're
stretched to become a vocabulary that
people use when expressing that senior
it's because one echo saw another and
the comparison county generation of
generation and no one said oh you've
copied this performance something
different out there starting to become a
domain of familiarity of the residents
so that people are content so that
people would understand when this was an
appropriate this is where cultures with
the plenty of tradition and stability so
I guess in a world where we can modify
these things in is it or this is IP and
it's now mine we don't want anyone else
to do it it's about building reference
and contracts and other text you know
famous the foundational text plus the
wizard of oz knows all about this that
but if you look at home if you look at
these foundations of Western literature
the Bible Shakespearean plays what you
see in every case is heavy-duty recycle
your all kind of narrative
woven together and bound up the new ways
fixed it's true but that's not to say
that behind them is a highly a lot of
other texts that are doing the same
thing history of Texas Romeo and Juliet
has you know countless interracial
coping is another great example where
you can take the language of web 2.0 and
you can go back to this lucky is still
today but it's also a long-term full
permission you could you could say the
very same thing about default music for
example right that folk songs are
developed by communities people
collaborate and participate they
repurpose they modify them they cut and
they mix languages that we're using
today to talk about you know flickr and
friendster and maybe some of the stuff
that people are doing in the music world
matchups in whatever in the visual world
so my point again is that because we
live in a world with these are now
technologically enabled you can go back
and see if that didn't exist earlier
than you know what 15 and then there are
a lot of lessons to be learned a lot of
people come together and there's
different skill sets I think this is a
great instance of participatory culture
of collaborative culture of the values
that somehow we're very much part of an
agrarian past and that as we enter the
modified culture of the 20th century we
seem to louise's forget about what we
have today are technologies that are
helping us to go back
we discovered that so I want to just end
with the Karl Marx quote the right place
to do it history repeats itself first
time is tragedy the septum is for
example there's all there's a lot of
wisdom I don't mean to say that it's all
been said before that there's nothing
new Under the Sun obviously we have new
affordances with our new technologies
networking and participation in the
central especially things like go
collective intelligence are in a certain
sense much easier and probably we're
transforming I mean we're really pushing
those those practices in whole new
directions than we've ever seen before
with foreign days in making your fault
zones but the elements are out there and
there are tons of lessons out there so
that we don't come down so if you're
anything you want to pursue to talk
about
sure
yeah behind I mean I gave you these four
visions and television and behind each
of them were where corporate
constituencies so the film industry
clearly thought TV is maybe not a bad
idea they use our cinemas the arm
electronics industry one of the radio
model there were also governmental
constituencies and there were really
very strong fights between the various
ministries you know Hitler's
administrative structure so he always
kept these guys fighting with one
another so that you didn't have to so
one of the big fights was between the
post Ministry which have an
infrastructure that did all the wiring
in the hardware and all that and the
post had traditionally Daniel a
controller of news they controlled the
news wires the wire service and so they
weren't allowed one bit of programming
and it was why humans but everything
else they did the propaganda ministry
was charged with and both of these
ministries and we had to fight over the
monthly license financing source so even
back in those days there was a licence
fee and these two ministries had to
fight each month over who got what
Sheriff the most revenue huge cultural
difference between them so the post
ministry guides were usually second or
third generation engineers that open the
universities were talented smart
engineers the propaganda ministry had a
low number on your party bad you would
probably permanently eligible to get a
job I think it was party clowns it was
Bavarian buffoons that we serve not a
very high quality people with exception
of some of them really quite brilliant
intelligent leadership by the way it's
interesting to look at the roots of
advertising because a lot of where
advertising here he comes from is in
Austria and Germany in the century up
until the 20s and then when Hitler
enters the scene because it kind of
split one community sort of
a lot of it winds up on Madison Avenue
at Lazarus golden equipped with radios
from Paul Berg those are those are
geysers video training in Germany and
Austria the other group lined up on the
bill Helms classic doing propaganda so
they didn't have some bright guys in the
ministry but anyway the ministry stated
one another one of the great finds from
Germany was am a document on the future
of television post-victory Nazi
television so after we win the war
what's the what's the 20-year plan this
just commissioned by the post ministry
and as far as I can tell its main kam
dishing which to use television is the
way to annihilate the propaganda
ministry and they had a I think of
really profound insight has said look we
don't we only control live news so what
we'll do is we're going to build a cable
cable news network it's going to cover
regulating I mean a lot of the focus of
scholarship on the Nazi period goes on
imagery and leni riefenstahl is
inspiring you know the films that are
still running in return for the Willis
killed band in Britain because if you'd
is just you can't not come out of that
film and not see if we focus on the
visual strategies and uplifting music
and all that stuff I think this is so
much
this becomes a whole lot more
interesting problem but this was a true
sir terrific that's like having a ringer
in the front
right so i would say rather than
solutions lessons look to the Past for
lessons see how they tried to grapple
with and see what worked and what didn't
they and see if there's any anything
that they tried it seems like we can
they reported into the president you
know how could we know that we're doing
but we're here where we are today
because we've all learned pretty well in
the past none of us got where we are in
life without picking up a lot of lessons
good and bad and all I'm saying is let's
just expand the framework a little bit
and rather than writing off the passage
like oh these or cups we all know what
the book is you know that's an absolute
technology or whatever like aren't many
of our own media points today are very
much and see you know for good or bad
what worked what didn't work how they
how they imagine what their you can
often spot problems that haven't yet
surfaced it could well in the right
conditions now again the danger here a
little bit is that it's easy to
misunderstand me a saint it all happened
before it's all going to happen again
and that's trafficking each of these
media working differently these have
different affordances and clearly that's
the case today we have very different
things possible but they're also doing
this number of similarities and so let's
take advantage of those similarities to
put new questions to the past and learn
what we can from it rather than just
referencing old books that don't really
we all have to think about that but what
I'll say this one of the curiosity
things and one of the things that's
interesting is when we look behind as
historically we're tend to be able to
see a pretty clear developmental path
you see the path that we know all these
roads in the world and we've walked one
and you can look back and say well
that's how we got here but it's those
other roads so it's parallel like let's
say in 20 years time when it's going to
be one of those things that people you
know we're going to scratch their head
wasn't there some what would have been
the competitive environment for
broadband way back when 20 or 30 years
ago so that's one stretching my own
isn't over Jim there but it's probably
well I think that's a really good
descriptive description of the method I
mean what I think you need to do is to
kind of go back to those moments when
something is anything let's just look at
whether then what were the spectrum of
options how do people imagine how do
they deploy it what are the winners and
losers in line rather than what we tend
to do which is sort of pick the winning
run and so here's how they got
successful you know that's not the story
I mean that's part of the story but a
whole lot of the other effect could be
half the standards could be regulatory
environment it could be hotter than one
things could just be a sort of kool-aid
blu-ray discs just could be bad timing
but when you go back to that moment and
look at it in all of its corners to get
ends are every bit as instructed as the
winning so so I think that's a really
apt description of you so much more when
i'm looking to how cases you know when i
look at how to do sometimes it takes it
to counter this stuff but a lot of times
it's more people want to know how did
they do it
well I mean yourself do a lot of
examples to take telephone which was up
you know entered the world unregulated
program I'll be gets regulated
relatively quickly but I mean there's
been some good work on the Hamish where
you can look at any of these
technologies in different cultural
settings to see how people have really
come up with quite different ways of
purposing so I mean I think it happens a
lot regulations steps in at a certain
point because it's a culminating Winston
somewhere in the middle like the third
or fourth step it's a law of the
suppression of granted potential and
that's the moment at which regulators
step in and say businesses you know
industries because it's you can't just
keep changing standards it just makes
consumers miserable it makes your
competition makes everyone miserable so
they like to fix it and hold it and
eventually you'll find sort of spin-off
technologies like missing a recorder
sort of where the publix do it all the
time so the Napster story would be for
every technology they are those stories
some are a little with television for
example you can see where for its time
while radios are great when right
because we know that people made their
own radios and they put out their own
syndrome and it was a two-way medium
until that stabilization process took
place in which case we can buy radio and
listen to what someone else may be safe
so that those early games would be
really interesting television starts
that way except television is pretty
high voltage and the amateur movement
those that survive quickly got out of
the amateur business because it was yeah
so in that case there's an example of a
technology that's a little bit too too
perilous but history of computing
history you'll see in this museum in the
history of computing at MIT where model
trains turn it were kids fascinated with
model trains that's here is it heavy the
model thing
how that morphs into the kind of stuff
that we're doing that this building is a
test